mais d'abord l'europe l'europe ces
valeurs de paix sa refondation au menu
du discours d' emmanuel macron à
strasbourg fabien becker face à poutine
et à la guerre l'europe affiche son
unité devant les parlementaires
européens emmanuel macron a salué les
efforts des vingt-sept pour soutenir le
rally ukrainien un combat pour la
démocratie et l'état de droit a déclaré
le président de la république nous
oeuvrons en européen
pour la préservation de la souveraineté
et de l'intégrité territoriale de
l'ukraine pour le retour de la paix sur
notre continent
il n'appartient qu'à l'ukraine de
définir les conditions des négociations
avec la russie
mais notre devoir est d'être à ses côtés
pour obtenir le cessez le feu fait bâtir
la paix
l'ukraine qui pourrait être appelé à
rejoindre une communauté politique
européenne emmanuel macron appelle de
ses voeux en attendant une éventuelle
procédure d'adhésion à strasbourg le
président a surtout plaidé pour une
europe plus indépendante et plus
efficace pour cela il a ouvert la porte
à une réforme des textes européens l'une
des voies de cette réforme
est la convocation d'une convention de
révision des traités
c'est une proposition du parlement
européen et je l'approuvent une réforme
qui permettrait notamment aux 27 de
prendre des décisions à la majorité
qualifiée plutôt qu'à l'unanimité
plusieurs pays comme la pologne la
finlande ou la suède ont déjà fait
savoir qu'ils s'opposaient à ce projet
emmanuel macron quant à lui a poursuivi
sa tournée européenne par une visite à
berlin
et on peut dire que c'est une semaine
macron qui commence dans notre actualité
politique on en débat tout de suite avec
mes invités emilie asap as qui ont jour
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes communiquant
de politique jean garrigues bonsoir ont
surgi à mieux vaut si vous êtes
historien président du comité d'histoire
parlementaire et vous publiez la
tentation du sauveur histoire d'une
passion française 7 aux éditions payot
mathieu sous pierre bonsoir essayiste
auteur 2022 la flambée populiste c'est
chez plon il est ici recrute pas ils
trahissent politique au soir laetitia
bienvenue à vous l'europe on commence
par ça il me lisent appel ce qui
évidemment c'était déjà un marqueur des
mamelles macron dans sa première
campagne présidentielle pendant son
premier mandat on peut dire que la crise
sanitaire que la guerre en ukraine ça ça
a validé ce son engagement il dit
l'europe s'est réveillée alors c'est
vrai qu'il a été ça a été un axe fort
dans en 2010 est déjà dans son programme
avec la crise sanitaire il a été porteur
en effet dû d'énergie européenne il est
allé jusqu'au bout des choses les
financements le pacte les vaccins il y
avait tout cet engouement est là on le
retrouve très ambitieux alors je pense
qu'il ya aussi un pied n'est un petit
peu à son probable opposant numéro un
que représente jean luc mélenchon qui
lui veut déroger veut désobéi aux règles
européennes
donc c'est une sorte de pied de nez de
s'opposer de dire moi je suis pro
européen on va réformer l'europe mais
l'europe est bonne l'europe est bonne
pour nous après moi je me suis posé la
question d'ailleurs il gesticule et
beaucoup j'ai eu l'impression de voir sa
vie comme dans les entreprises les gens
qui font des cdd team building on
appelle ça c'est à dire en gros on
essaie de gala et moi il fallait motive
voilà on motive parce que c'est des
grandes ambitions mais qu'est ce que
c'est si on si on regarde simplement sur
la communauté politique qu'ils proposent
c'est une chambre d'attentes c'est une
chambre d'attentes pour l'ukraine est ce
qu'on en a les moyens est-ce que ce
qu'ils proposent en infrastructures en
sécurité tout ce qui met derrière est ce
qu'on en a les moyens donc c'est un très
bel affichage on retrouve le maquereau
en 2010 est très volontaire sur l'europe
maintenant est-ce que derrière j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup il ya
beaucoup de paroles dans ce que nous
propose emmanuel macron depuis quinze
jours maintenant est ce que la réalité
les actes seront la réforme et l'europe
on a vu ce que ça a donné en 2004 2005
en france c'est très compliqué on a
quand même un espèce de traumatisme du
vote sur les traités européens on a dit
non puis revienne par la fenêtre voilà
il arrive
les mains dans le cambouis il va falloir
manoeuvrer très habilement pour aller là
dedans la volonté et bonne l'ambition
est bonne on joue sur les actions iliad
et à certains pays européens et qui ont
conduit ce n'était pas forcément
favorable à ce qu'on voit les traiter
jean garrigues strasbourg puis berlin
c'est certainement parce que marine le
pen ou jean luc mélenchon aurait fait
dans une première première semaine de
mandat c'est sage est clair ça qui est
intéressant bon c'est vrai que ça a été
très bien dit emma daumas qu'on revient
à l'origine en 2017 faut se souvenir que
c'est que la presse anglo saxonne et
fait presque le le le pilier le le
moteur de l'europe avec le déclin d'un
gué à merkel il devenait l'homme de
l'heure et puis ç'a toujours été son son
adn politique donc là c'est assez
cohérent que a de plus il à cette
fonction de président de l'union
européenne qui va bientôt s'achever en
face et il a il est en charge de
l'europe et la crise du coc vide là
évidemment replacer sur sur orbite mais
ce qui est surtout intéressant sur le
plan idéologique et sur le plan
politique c'est que effectivement c'est
ce qui ce qui s'est passé au lors de
cette élection présidentielle c'est
quand même le choc l'opposition entre un
candidat qui représente justement soit
l'ouverture européenne et deux candidats
celle qui était face à lui au second
tour est le troisième bloc celui qui
représentait jean luc mélenchon qui sont
des euro sceptiques voire des anti
européens alors marine le pen elle a mis
un peu d'eau dans son vin de de sa de sa
critique européenne de son souverainisme
et elle reste une candidate
souverainiste et puis jean luc mélenchon
c'est une crédit très forte de de
l'europe voit les problèmes que cela
pose d'ailleurs pour le nul c'est pour
eux pour les socialistes qui sont
associés mais qui n'ont pas forcément
les mêmes idées sur loeb bref ça veut
dire que là il ya quand même un enjeu
national aussi par rapport à cette prise
de position de 2ème année de maquereaux
et est un enjeu qui peut-être on en a
pas suffisamment parlé dans cette
campagne présidentielle bon il ya
beaucoup de sujets comme ça qu'ils n'ont
pas été suffisamment évoqué mais qui est
quand même un sujet central pour
l'avenir quand on a la guerre en ukraine
quand on a le projet de réarmer l'europe
de faire enfin une europe de la défense
ou une europe de la de la protection des
frontières en fayyad et il ya une europe
sociale jeu l'oubli parce que c'est
quand même quelque chose qui était aussi
déjà dans le projet macron à l'époque
n'a pas du tout été avancé donc c'est
vraiment un enjeu un enjeu majeur et qui
je le répète qu'on a envie de devoir
quand même bien ressurgir dans le débat
français
mathieu soupière quelles questions vous
retenez vous de cette journée européenne
du président réélu qu'est ce qui vous
frappe qu'est-ce qui vous marque mais
c'est qu'encore une fois l'europe mais
ça ne date pas d'aujourd'hui l'europe
est au coeur pour le coût de notre
actualité politique à nous elle s'est
réinvitée en fait dans notre histoire ce
qui est d'un style très souvent le cas
dans les années précédant et je dirais
par ailleurs de façon positive pendant
très longtemps l'europe et a pu être
présente dans les campagnes d'ailleurs
essentiel à avec un vrai euroscepticisme
avec une notion de bouc émissaire ça n'a
pas du tout été le cas pendant cette
campagne présidentielle et je nuancerais
quand même il y a chez jean luc
mélenchon ou en tout cette cause à à la
gauche de la gauche depuis longtemps un
discours européen qui est moins
eurosceptiques encore une fois que pour
la construction d'une autre race est
vrai ça date de 2005 et en 2005 déjà les
tenants du non disait ça n'est pas un
non à l'europe c'est un non à l'europe
des traités libéraux donc de ce point de
vue là il faut pas les confondre avec
avec marine le pen non on observe que
depuis le coc vide et à plus forte
raison avec la crise ukrainienne y
compris dans l'opinion en fait la
demande d'europe se fait plus est lui
plus accentuée hier que les français
sont moins euro sceptique qu'avant pour
autant et je pointe une contradiction si
l'europe a été très présente au moment
du coc vide et la très présente dans les
dernières semaines y compris dans la
campagne présidentielle on a vu que les
questions internationales continuaient
de peut intéresser nos compatriotes
c'est que au moment où on se posait des
questions assez fondamental en matière
de politiques y compris de modèles
contre modèle de l'europe démocratique
contre eux un modèle anglo saxon ou par
ailleurs un modèle chinois par exemple
où évidemment un modèle autoritaire
russes les français se concentrait sur
la question du pouvoir d'achat voilà en
terme de projet de société est un peu
fermé même si les deux peuvent être liés
parce que c'est vrai que vous parlez
tous de cette europe fondamentale d'un
discours d' emmanuel macron dans le
premier quinquennat est donc dans le
second de vraiment ce socle pour la
politique internationale pour peut-être
les enjeux géopolitiques et c'est enfin
qui est intéressé par l'europe mais
vraiment je me pose de façon très
prosaïque et très premier degré quand
vous l'avez dit à l'instant c'est vrai
que on a du mal alors peut-être que
c'est le rôle des médias des
journalistes aussi évidemment je me mets
dans l'eau à faire comprendre prendre
conscience parce que évidemment que les
enjeux sont fondamentaux aux français
parce que cette question finalement et
toujours mais il me semble toujours un
repoussoir pour les populations je pense
qu'ils sont prêts restant ce que les
français comprennent très bien et les
traités libéraux ils ont très bien
compris quelle incidence ça avait sur
leur vie au quotidien sur sur des choses
vraiment de la réalité si il se faisait
qu'ils sont pas si naïf que ça par
contre là où on peut être critique parce
que vous disiez on est en demande
d'europe mais il ya quand même là ne
serait-ce que là les sanctions
économiques on voit bien que la hongrie
bloc là sur quelque chose qui serait un
levier quand même assez fort vis-à-vis
des russes c'est à dire un embargo sur
le pétrole russe on sent bien que ça
bloque quand est ce qu'on va décider on
a décidé ça dans un an ou dans deux ans
la gare sera l'ukraine elle sera dans un
état catastrophique et on a eu ça pour
les vaccins on a eu ça pour la santé
donc oui je pense que les français sont
critiques mais je pense qu'ils sont
intéressés après c'est la communication
c'est mon métier c'est vrai qu'on a du
mal à communiquer sur l'europe on voit
que le mastodonte technocratique on
critique beaucoup et on voit pas au
quotidien ce qui as qu'on pourrait
réformer parce que dans le dos par
exemple à sion à la communication ceux
là même le travail des correspondants
qui sont à la brussels evs asus ou faire
un travail pédagogique un peu doux trois
éléments d'explication il ya celui de la
des institutions de la compréhension par
rapport à une architecture
institutionnelle qui est qu un peu
lassant 6-1 contre 1,6 pour le relais
français déjà que les français ne
comprennent pas très bien à quoi servent
le parlement l'assemblée le sénat
l'europe et alors
allons-y pour le parlement rocha
commission européenne est elle au
conseil repas ils n'y comprennent rien
ça c'est une certitude
ils sont certainement là aussi et c'est
pour ça que la question de l' unanimité
et du vote qualifié c'est quand même un
aspect très important parce qu'on
s'aperçoit que c'est un élément de
blocage récurrent et que ça peut être
ils peuvent ils peuvent le comprendre et
puis aussi la manière dont a été
présentée l'europe c'est pour ça que je
parlais tout leur d'euros
d'euroscepticisme de d'euros critiques
etc c'est vrai que notamment du côté de
rassemblement national mais pas
simplement il ya eu une habitude depuis
trente ans de d'imputer toutes les
heures toutes les difficultés notre
système politique aux contraintes
européennes et là il ya un déficit
d'explication de communication par
rapport à ceux qui sont des pro
européens on voit bien et ce déficit
d'explication on peut considérer qu'ils
commencent au moment du référendum sur
le traité de en 2005 parce que là on
voit très bien de quelle manière d'une
manière à mon sens un peu caricatural on
a associé les pro-européens aux élites
et les anti européens à ceux qui
défendent est le poids que ça c'est
l'accès des populistes et les extrêmes
c'est sûr ils n'ont voulu faire de cette
date et c'est vrai que le référendum la
réponse n'a pas été prises en compte
c'est vrai mais ensuite il ya une
instrumentalisation dans le récit
politique de cet acte un peu fondateur
de schisme envies vos besoins dix ans
les élites il soit disant le peuple qui
je pense qu'il ya un autre écueil et on
sait que la danse que vous dites si on
critique lock on est jugé comme
extrémistes ou populistes vraiment je
pense que ça c'est un discours quand
même que c'est partager en france sont
les alors que le rock you have et
raymond couderc quelque chose qu'on a
critiqué de l'europe mais il ya des
choses réelles il ya les réalités il ya
des lourdeurs et des choses qui nous
soient imposés qu'ils ont dit ni tête 1
quand même et on va terminer là dessus
parce qu'il ya plein plein d'autres
faits mais c'est vrai matière d'accueil
d'ailleurs quand emmanuel macron dans
son discours cet après-midi évoque la
possibilité de revoir en partie traite
europe 1 c'est bien si c'est bien une
façon de dire que ça va bien qu'il ya
nécessité de rénovation alors je sais
pas si on peut dire que ça fonctionne
pas bien évidemment c'est une
construction par définition perfectible
difficile encore une fois c'est un
projet politique tout à fait inédit mais
qui ne ressemble à aucun autre et donc
évidemment c'est difficile mais encore
une fois on a pu dire on a été nombreux
à dire qu'à la faveur des crises
récentes la construction européenne avec
progressé à une vitesse qu'on avait
rarement connu et encore une fois en
dépit de tout ce qu'on vient de dire est
que je partage on observe que depuis
quelques années la demande de
construction européenne dans l'opinion
française progresse les français
réclament davantage l'europe ce n'est
encore une fois est à contre courant par
rapport à ce qu'on avait observé au
cours des précédents dix années alors on
va ouvrir le débat maintenant sur cette
séquence politique à d'ailleurs démarré
laetitia samedi avec le discours d'
emmanuel macron des cérémonies
d'investiture
qu'est ce qui vous a frappé dans
écouter dans cette cérémonie
d'investiture somme toute classique
arrêt sobre l'elysée de toute façon
avait prévenu que ce serait comme ça il
ya un moment du discours qui m'a laissé
quoi tu vois là c'est le moment où
emmanuel macron nous apprend que les
français ne l'ont pas réélu
le peuple français
n'a pas prolongé le mandat qui s'achève
commencé le 14 mai 2017 ce peuple
nouveau différent d'il ya cinq ans a
confié un président nouveau un mandat
nouveau on peut aller me dire tomac
c'est une figure de style il une astuce
rhétorique à pour faire passer le
message que bien sûr il a entendu les
colères les contestations et que et
changera sa façon de gouverner donc
jusqu'à lui même puisqu'il dit qu'il
sera un président nouveau mais quand
même il fallait l'oser à cette phrase on
est un peu vraiment la limite de la
tabula rasa en mode méthode coué oui
c'est quoi l'objectif est médiocre
michel lemay peuvent faire oublier tous
les traits négatifs à qui ont entouré
son premier mandat les échecs la
mauvaise vie j'ai manuel macro et donc
nouveau ce n'est plus celui d'avant et
de l'idée sous jacente c'est évidemment
le rassemblement le je vous ai compris
et j'inclus aussi dans les français bien
sûr tous ceux qui ont voté pour moi mais
qui n'était pas forcément convaincu ou
qu'ils ont fait pour faire barrage à
l'extrême droite et puis enfin c'est une
technique de communication apparemment
qui est en vogue en ce moment je ne fais
que constater ce qu'il est en train de
se passer mais vraiment dans les trois
dernières semaines c'est la prophétie
auto-réalisatrice prenez jean luc
mélenchon qui martèle depuis
l'entre-deux tours élisez moi premier
ministre alors qu'il sait que ses
chances à matignon so nul est bien
emmanuel macron dans le même dans la
même vague nous assène que les français
ont voté pour un président nouveau le
nouveau peuple français on frôle sous
couvert d'allégories politique la vérité
alternative c'était l'accord vérité
alternative où aller jusque là jean
garrigues c'est vrai qu'il prend un
risque quand même emmanuel macron parce
qu'on va guetter le retour de jupiter
les uns et les autres ce qui se passe
c'est que ce qui lui arrive d'être réélu
comme ça sans période de cohabitation
c'est quelque chose d'inédit et il faut
se souvenir que le deuxième septennat de
françois mitterrand et le quinquennat de
jacques chirac ont pas été des réussites
flamboyantes un président comme emmanuel
macron qui part avec seulement 34 % de
confiance de taux de confiance des
français forcément il faut qu'il dise
qu'il va être différent parce que ce qui
s'est passé dans le premier quinquennat
l'image qui la laisse est une image
négative donc alors qu'il a réussi un
certain nombre de choses il a passé
l'obstacle des de la pandémie de la cre
plus ou moins pied bien négociée à la
crise en ukraine etc et d'autres choses
mais forcément il faut essayer de se
renouveler d'où le de renaissance pour
son pur pour le parti ce qui est ce qui
finalement pour moi d'ailleurs pas si
mal que ça est-ce que la république en
marche sa patte tellement marché très
truc à renaissance c'est me semble assez
nécessaire et surtout il me semble
nécessaire de reconstruire un espace
politique au centre enfin au centre
droit centre gauche mais ça c'est une
autre c'est une autre question donc
voilà c'est évidemment c'est un artifice
rhétorique mais il me semble il me
semblait indispensable
il ne pouvait pas rester sur cette image
d'une continuité et je le répète dans
quelque chose où il est en pleine
expérimentation de l'innovation parce
que je répète c'est le premier président
à être réélu hors cohabitation c'est
quelque chose de difficile donc il faut
qu'il invente un nouveau modèle il faut
qu'il avait
trouvé assez nouveau quand même sur la
forme déjà dix minutes j'avais jamais vu
ça chez les indiens de macron l'a refait
un petit peu aujourd'hui presque un
petit peu plus long mais et puis de
sobriété c'est vrai que c'était
peut-être pas un président nouveau mais
un homme nouveau j'ai eu l'impression de
voir quelqu'un qui était un petit peu
les le poids de son expérience peser un
petit peu sur ses épaules et on le
sentait il y avait les mots qui allaient
avec on a parlé de considération de
respect dont il y avait cette idée de
d'image un petit peu écornée quand il
disait à traverser la rue et je vous
trouve du boulot ou le pognon des
dingues pour la caf pour les allocations
il a essayé de changer après en effet
c'est beaucoup de promesses et c'est
étonnant parce que c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui a été élu malgré ce que
mélenchon a dit il a été lu correctement
on peut pas dire il a eu quand même 58%
on attendait pas autant et pourtant il
est en justification c'est comme si
lille a cru il a cru à ce qu'on lui a
dit il a cru qu'il était mal élu et il
est en justification et il veut apporter
du nouveau il nous a parlé de jeunesse
il nous a parlé d'écologie il a parlé de
2010 le ferai pas m'étendre on sera en
train de commenter un résident les
soutiens pas compte de ces un peu
schizophrène est-ce qu'il va vraiment le
faire c'est à dire que là vous avez dit
jupiters mais les jupiter est déjà là
pour les législatives c'est lui qui en a
parlé tout à l'heure et non des
candidatures donc quelque part il ya
quelque chose qui est par nature
inhérents à lui il n'y arrivera pas de
la communication
on peut pas incarner un personnage avec
le discours avec les messages totalement
différent de ce qu'on est
intrinsèquement ficelles
de l'application c'est la base quand on
veut travailler avec un homme politique
et là il me semble qu'il a fait un peu
beaucoup de mots beaucoup de commerces
vont souvent on jugera sur pièce
évidemment comme d'habitude mathieu sous
création se concentra sur ce tempo
politique et cette semaine qui qui sue à
force de retarder la nomination
du nouveau gouvernement il prend quand
même un risque emmanuel macron celui
d'un soufflé qui retombe est ce que je
veux dire parce que savait difficile de
surprendre ça va être difficile qu il ya
une sorte d'effet whaou aux rois à
quelle nouvelle quel nouveau
gouvernement il est vrai que on est dans
une situation inédite et donc le
président de la république peut presque
se permettre enfin de cet attentisme
parce que comme le disait jean garrigues
encore une fois il ya la dimension
inédite de la réélection du président
sortant ça c'est un fait majeur c'est à
dire que il à la longévité dont ont été
privés dont ont été privés tous ses
prédécesseurs sans avoir la confiance
donc effectivement ça créé de vraies
difficultés durée 5 ans en confiance
c'est déjà difficile durée 2 x 50 cent
confiance et même en suscitant pour
partie à un rejet assez vif c'est
extrêmement compliqué je relativise que
nous par nos impôts mais n'oublions pas
qu'il a terminé son premier mandat avec
un niveau de solidarité qui était quand
même plus élevé de peu quelques dessus
nicolas sarkozy est debout c'est tout à
fait juste c'est ce qui fait que lui a
pu non seulement se représenter
contrairement à françois hollande et
être réélu contrairement à nicolas
sarkozy mais encore une fois si on se
compare en particulier que ce qu'on
observe dans les autres pays européens
notamment on voit bien quand on a des
gouvernants qui en général sorte du
pouvoir tout à fait et sort et est donc
encore une fois emmanuel macron n'était
pas mort mais sa situation n'est pas si
simple que ça alors je reviens par
rapport à ce que vous disiez sur la
question de la nouveauté donc oui quand
même pour partie je dirais que ce pré
sident ce président est nouveau et que
ça n'est pas une vérité alternative ou
juste un effet de communication pour une
raison simple il y avait en 2010 est une
très grande continuité entre le premier
tour de l'élection et le deuxième tour
de l'élection une forme de cohérence
dans ce qu'incarnait en fait la promesse
qu'un carnet emmanuel macron ce coup ci
c'est tout à fait différent il ya une
campagne au premier tour qui l'a mené à
droite et puis compte tenu encore une
fois du très fort score de la gauche
inattendus ont fait rater j politique
mais je termine ace les jeux termine sur
une réalité politique précisément s'il a
essayé lui en 2017 avec les voix du
centre gauche il a été élu en 2000 22 2
avec les voix du centre droit donc par
définition c'est un président nouveau
qui a été élu en 2022 y compris parce
que l'équation politique les très
différentes et d'ailleurs je n'ose y
assume en fait aujourd'hui c'est un cap
et à son positionnement à droite je ne
dirais pas ça je dirais que en tout cas
il a une forme d'agilité qui lui permet
d'être éventuellement cohérent mais
quand même en se faisant élire par le
centre-gauche en 2017 par le centre
droit en 2022 et en 2017 après avoir été
élu par le centre gauche il se choisit
presque logiquement pour rassembler un
premier ministre qui vient du centre
droit et on voit bien à la faveur des
indiscrétions qu'on a entendu ces jours
ci que même s'il a un peu de mal il
prend son temps en tout cas à se nommer
un nouveau premier ministre ou une
nouvelle première ministre en fait il a
été élu par une majorité de centre-droit
et apparemment il se cherche une femme
qui quitte qui incarnerait plutôt leçon
de droit pour matignon sur la retraite
mais sur la conditionnalité du rsa qui
ose
balayés voir il a proposé à jean castex
de rester ce qui semble de rester fidèle
non ils n'ont pas pour le quinquennat de
respect pour faire la jonction jusqu'à
aux législatives mais alors c'est sain
c'est surprenant avec ce discours du
président oui mais même hors autre
paradoxe autre contradiction alors qu'il
prétend dans son discours de samedi un
quart d incarner une forme de renouveau
que l'opl eux sont partis le parti de la
majorité présidentielle change de nom et
devenir renaissance on voit que les
investitures en tout cas qui ont été
données ce week-end pour les
législatives dans l'immense majorité des
cas c'est une reconduction des sortants
donc en tout cas la nouveauté elle ne
parle elle ne passera pas par le
personnel politique alors justement on
va en parler d investiture pour ces
législatives avec marion vivre bonsoir
marion bienvenus on fait le point sur
les derniers mouvements du côté du
groupe ensemble donc c'est la nouvelle
majorité présidentielle ont
effectivement puisque le mercato se
poursuit du côté d' ensemble en vue des
élections législatives on rappelle prévu
les 12 et 19 juin prochains une
quatrième et dernière liste de candidats
est attendue d'ici ce soir mais le
week-end à d'ores et déjà été marquée
par quelques prises significative par la
macro ni première d'entre elles celle de
robin reda ce proche de valérie pécresse
que vous découvrez à l'antenne qui a
participé à toute la campagne
présidentielle en tant que porte parole
qui tu les as l'air pour la majorité
présidentielle il sera candidat sous
l'étiquette donc ensemble dans la 7e
circonscription de l'essonne elle c'est
un départ qui a beaucoup surpris puisque
samedi matin encore à quelques heures du
conseil national il tractait avec des
militants et l'air sur le marché de
juvisy sur orge réaction de christian
jacob romareda aura face à lui une
candidate et l'air on est soi et l'air
soit l heure où m et cette ligne
s'appliquent à tous a rappelé christian
jacob en tout cas chez les républicains
ce départ a un goût amer puisque le
député âgé de 30 ans faisait partie des
figures montantes du parti autre
transfuge celui d'une proche d'eux
nicolas sarkozy il s'agit de constance
le grip celle qui était jusqu'à présent
députés les républicains est investi
dans la sixième circonscription des
hauts-de-seine là aussi sous l'étiquette
ensemble sur twitter voici ce qu'elle
écrit attaché aux idées et projets de la
droite et du centre je réponds
favorablement à l'appel au rassemblement
lancé par le chef de l'état en
responsabilité
enfin autre déconvenue pour le parti de
christian jacob le choix de la candidate
claudine eu de renoncer à l'investiture
et l'air dans le nord pour apporter son
soutien au ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin candidat dans la 10e
circonscription
et puis ce lundi les regards sont
également tournés vers le département de
l'indre et puis particulièrement la 5e
circonscription qui est celle du député
et président du groupe plr à l'assemblée
nationale dames yared on le disait très
proche d'un ralliement à emmanuel macron
pour le moment le suspense reste entier
chez l air la circonscription lui est
pour le moment réservé mais face à lui
ensemble elle n'a encore investi aucun
candidat en tout cas c'est ralliement
reste très en deçà de ce qu'avait pu
envisager nicolas sarkozy l'ancien
président de la république avait soutenu
un rapprochement avec emmanuel macron
évoqué la possibilité de voir une
quarantaine de députés et l'air basculer
dans le giron d'ensemble mais on en est
très loin puisqu'au final ils seraient
environ moins de 10 à avoir passé le pas
en tout cas tout c'est investir doivent
être bouclées tous ces investitures doit
être bouclé d'ici ce soir car à les
candidats investis sous la bannière
ensemble ont rendez-vous demain matin
aux docks d'aubervilliers en banlieue
parisienne pour participer à une journée
de séminaire et de cohésion merci marion
pour tous ces détails jean garrigues est
ce que ça vous étonne y assez peu
finalement on vient d'en faire la liste
de prise de guerre pardon du terme et
l'air franchement ça ne m'étonne pas ce
que j'ai toujours pensé que du côté dlr
la situation n'était pas aussi
désespérée que du côté du parti
socialiste et que tout était réuni pour
qu'il préserve un groupe consistant
alors ce sera peut-être entre 60 et et
maximum 100 députés mais il ya tous les
tous les éléments la transition doit
elle se serait un casier mais c'est pour
ça que je vous dis que le seuil de 50 60
me paraîtrait raisonnable
il ya tous les éléments sont réunis pour
que il préserve donc ce groupe d des
républicains et donc l'attractivité de
de la renaissance et de l'ensemble soit
soient moindres chez chez eux donc ça
c'est pas vraiment une une surprise moi
je pense que ceux qui ceux qui font
remarquer c'est aussi que emmanuel
macron a renoncé à l'idée d'un parti
unique c'est déjà une évolution par
rapport à ce qu'on peut attendre et a
accepté cette fédération avec horizon
agir et puis et puis le modem bien sujet
mais une habile modem et que dans la
distribution des sièges bien il y en
aura une centaine pour le modem 50 je
crois pour à peu près pour 58 pour
horizon
le le jupiter isme va être un tout petit
peu moins présent pesant sur sur la
majorité et je pense que la manière
ensuite de fonctionner va devoir évoluer
parce que il y avait déjà quand on
interrogeait notamment l' aile gauche de
la république omar j'aime pas parler de
maquereaux nîmes et la république en
marche on voyait qu'il y avait quand
même des tensions très fortes dans le
groupe parlementaire face à aux excès du
pouvoir personnel de la verticalité
jupitérienne et donc je pense que dans
ce deuxième quinquennat il va falloir
modifier un petit peu le le mode de
fonctionnement alors sur cette capacité
de résistance du parti à l'air les
républicains une réaction celle du yeux
de l'eurodéputé
françois-xavier bellamy et peu de nos
parlementaires très peu de nos candidats
une infime minorité accrue par
opportunisme devoir rejoindre les rangs
de la majorité qui vont y aller damien
abad par exemple qui était le patron des
républicains a semblé très peu nombreux
au conseil national nous nous étions des
centaines réuni samedi et nous avons
voté une motion pour dire notre volonté
de rester indépendant de rester dans
l'opposition elle venait de macron cette
motion a été adoptée à l'unanimité pas
une voix contre pas une abstention est
ce que qu'on ne dise plus que les
républicains sont déchirés la ligue 1
savent ce qu'ils ont à faire
reconstruire la droite pas seulement les
républicains reconstruire la droite et
retrouver la confiance des français
alors les républicains pas déchirer ce
qu il est un peu optimiste quand même
je note qu'il y a peu de temps alors que
la campagne n'était pas encore terminée
juste après la présentation par emmanuel
macron de son programme présidentiel
valérie pécresse avait crié à la
spoliation quand même
considérant que programmes des manuels
macron était quasiment le sien donc en
tout cas sur le fond on a du mal à
imaginer que les candidats aujourd'hui à
la députation sous l'étiquette et l'air
soit tellement en désaccord ou tellement
mal à l'aise avec ce que propose
emmanuel macron comme projet politique
la première dimension et la deuxième
dimension quand même ce sont les scores
je re vérifiait en fait l'ailé alors les
projections pour les législatives à
partir des scores à la présidentielle
sont pour partie fictive mais je
regardais quand même que les
républicains ne se porte pas si bien que
ça voire même se porte très mal et pas
tellement pas tellement mieux en élite
et que le parti socialiste quand vous
regardez les 577 circonscriptions
emmanuel macron est arrivé en tête dans
en gros 260 circonscription marine le
pen dans 200 circonscription et la
gauche dans une centaine de
circonscriptions
donc jean luc mélenchon qui se présente
comme le futur premier ministre
évidemment et au delà de l'intox enfin
je lui je lui souhaite évidemment je lui
souhaite évidemment super énorme
surprise
maintenant on en est loin des pompiers
de valérie pécresse c'est quand même
très intéressant il n'y a que deux
circonscriptions où elle arrive elle
dépasse les 12 et demi pour cent deux
circonscriptions sur 577 donc je ne sais
pas si à la fin on se tombe les
projections qui sont faites à partir de
la présidentielle il me semble que quand
même et la recherche
il était difficile de faire des
productions 100 députés
simplement que même avec un ancrage
territorial même avec un ancrage
territorial il a été difficile pour
valérie pécresse le faire partout en
france des scores corrects
il faudra que les électeurs aient l'air
pardon gens qui ont qui n'ont pas voté
pécresse qui ont un député sortant
qu'ils aiment bien fasse le chemin vers
le côté local c'est ce qu'ils ont ceux
qui n'ont pas voté pécresse les beautés
macro et qui ce coup ci ne voterai pas
des députés de la république en marche
mais pour le décor qu'il en soit dans la
couleur les couleurs que va avoir
l'assemblée c'est plutôt favorable quand
même au président parce que quoi qu'il
en soit moi je ferais je pas du tout
d'accord avec ce que vous disiez sur sur
l'ailé gauche de la majorité
2010cette fin du premier quinquennat
mais ils n'ont jamais fait parler d'eux
et d'ailleurs si on prend par exemple
jacques martin mais non il ya eu des
dissensions mais jamais on les a
entendus à la hauteur de faire changer
des décisions politiques ou des
orientations politiques sortis ils sont
sortis jacques merle et sans inscription
ils n'ont pas été cités des mini
frondeurs sinon c'est ce que je dis ils
n'ont pas été des frondeurs comme ceux
de dublin 4 en soit l'annoncé que ce
exploser le parent décédé mais mais là
non mais enfin groupe s'est constitué à
vis des villages était en privé ils
manifestaient à plusieurs reprises leur
l'ordre ils ont jamais réussi à nord
élargit encore son déficit sur la
méthodologie macro des et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui sur
l'allée la millions ce que je voulais
dire sur le sur les pourquoi je disais
que les républicains allaient peut-être
mieux s'en tirer que en tout cas s'en
tirait mieux que ce qu'on pouvait
anticiper c'est qu'il est possible aussi
et c'est ce qui s'était passé en 2017
par rapport à l'électorat du
rassemblement national et de reconquête
vous avez peut-être là une marge de
manoeuvre pour les pour les républicains
par exemple en 2017 marine le pen elle a
eu 9 9 députés alors qu'elle avait
qu'elle était quand même au deuxième
tour de l'élection donc lors des
élections législatives il peut y avoir
quand même des reports de voix des deux
dindes une partie de l'électorat du
rassemblement national un peu effrayé
par ce qu'on sait du rassemblement
national vers l'est vers l'est
républicain ça vaut bien un
transfert 2
le verre le centre reconquête d'eric
zemmour il s'en passait pas vrai qu'on
termine sur les ailes après on va avoir
un petit chapitre consacré à marine le
pen mathieu soutien il faut quand même
rappeler qu'ils avaient une offensive
avec nicolas sarkozy à sa tête alors
sauf grande surprise lors des dernières
investitures
renaissance qui vont être dévoilé dans
la soirée ça fait long feu on a raconté
pendant la campagne qui effectivement
emmanuel macron était un candidat
affaibli qui avait à composer avec deux
personnalités politiques fortes de la
droite qui incarnait un peu le passé
pour l'un et beaucoup l'avenir pour
l'autre c'est un nicolas sarkozy et
edouard philippe on constate
qu'effectivement du côté de nicolas
sarkozy ça ne décroche personnes ou
quasiment personne en tout cas 0
ralliement mais on observe aussi que
khalid et edouard philippe qu'on
annonçait comme l'homme fort du deuxième
quinquennat en tout cas pour ce qui est
des ralliements et du poids qu'ils
pèsent à l'intérieur de renaissance là
aussi en réalité il faut relativiser à
la dynamique il est un poids inférieur
de la confédération ensemble pas de pas
de renaissance parce qu'il veut oui il
vit
le parti présidentiel veut être
mais avec un poids plus limité qu'on
avait imaginé il nous reste quelques
minutes dans ce débat on termine autour
de l'entrée en campagne dans ces
législatives on peut le dire de marine
le pen c'était ce week-end et elle
choisit sa première cible c'est jean luc
mélenchon tuer la fable la fable de jean
luc mélenchon opposant les manuels
macron appelé à arrêter maintenant ça a
duré quinze jours ça a fait rire tout le
monde la réalité c'est que jean luc
mélenchon a fait élire emmanuel macron
voilà donc ça le discrédite absolument
pour pouvoir se mettre dans la posture
de l'opposant à emmanuel macron donc ils
jouent les fous du roi
et surjoue l'insolence à l'égard du
président emilie zapolsky c'est là c'est
clairement la place de premier ou
premier opposant opposante qui se joue
mais oui là elle s'est fait voler la
vedette à elle a été assez discrète elle
s'est mis en retrait même du 1er mai
donc toujours dans cette idée de l'image
un peu chaleureuse femme d'état en recul
hauteur de vue mais elle s'est
clairement fait voler la vedette par
jean luc mélenchon qui a réussi quand
même ce tour de force de cette union
bizarroïde mais qui est quand même une
union et qui peut peser au législatif je
sais pas jusqu'à quel auteur mais qui
pèsera de toute façon crédible si on
parle de communication politique c'est
là et pris la parole la semaine dernière
mais où les projecteurs braqués c'est la
nouvelle union et edel et surtout je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué elle a
reparlé la
d'immigration et de sécurité l art
parler de ça alors que pendant toute sa
campagne a été sur le pouvoir d'achat
très très bien d'ailleurs habilement
elle s'est lancée là dessus elle avait
présenté ce thème que les autres avaient
du mal à récupérer et là tout d'un coup
comme mia mélenchon et macron elle se
remet sur l'immigration et la sécurité
les fondamentaux du fn qu'elle avait
fait oublier dans cette espèce de phase
de diabolisation de normalisation mais
elle sait que celle axes différents sion
qui peut peser avec cet électorat de
droite elle parle du laxisme des manuels
macron et durera elle rapproche emmanuel
macron et mélenchon sur ces thématiques
s'est pas complètement idiot mais c'est
très difficile de se positionner avec
elle et pour terminer la fusion elle
peut pas la jouer avec reconquête parce
que c'est tous les habits de l'extrême
droite qu'elle ne veut plus avoir
zemmour lui a permis de se débarrasser
de ça pendant la campagne présidentielle
c'est extrême droite immigration tout ça
c'est lui qu'il prenait ça elle veut
surtout pas aller récupérer parce
qu'elle a formalisé un peu c'est un
cadeau de deux ou trois députés feu mais
ça l'a coincé parce que quelque part on
sait que les législatives sont pas
favorables pour le rassemblement
national donc il risque d'avoir plus que
neuf députés mais pas beaucoup beaucoup
mathieu zouk r je rebondis sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat quand même
parce que le futur gouvernement finir
par être nommé
dieudo macron 2 il va devoir aller vite
sur ces sur ces questions pour tenir une
partie en tout cas des promesses du
candidat macro oui et ça reste la
préoccupation numéro un des français ça
s'est encore confirmé et jean luc
mélenchon se présentait jusqu'à ces
derniers jours comme le futur premier
ministre de la france par ailleurs en
étant l'incarnation de ce qu'il nomme
les mêmes le bloc populaire
encore une fois les catégories
populaires à cette élection
présidentielle elles n'ont pas du tout
voté pour la gauche et c'est tout le
problème de la gauche qu'elle soit
désuni ou qu'elles soient unis à ce
stade elle ne parvient pas à reparler
aux catégories populaires et donc marine
le pen a raison de rappeler cette
réalité électorale l'a alors elle ne
fait pas de cette façon chiffrée mais
enfin jean-luc mélenchon a fait 22 % à
l'élection présidentielle a fait 42 % à
l'élection présidentielle et je reviens
à ma question des circonscriptions parce
que encore une fois faut pas faire de
projections trop précises mais faut
quand même mesurer quel est le rapport
de force marine le pen plus quand même
l'électorat d'eric zemmour parce que
marine le pen n'a pas intérêt à faire
d'accor avec reconquête c'est sûr mais
elle peut espérer évidemment récupérer
la france d'eric zemmour bourg parti
marine le pen plus eric zemmour c'est
plus de 12 5% dans 520 circonscription
autant pour emmanuel macron donc le
rapport de force il est quand même
sacrément rééquilibrer en sa faveur ce
que révèle ce scrutin ce qu'a révélé
cette présidentielle c'est que désormais
l'offre le rassemblement national et est
implantée partout dans le pays à
l'exception des grandes métropoles mais
si on met les grandes métropoles de côté
alors séparé hier les grandes métropoles
mais si on met les grandes métropoles de
côté les grandes villes les grandes
métropoles loeffel désormais le
rassemblement national approbation
toutes les régions de france toutes les
régions des présidentielles à l'élection
présidentielle et on rappelle que 2 5%
c'est ce seuil pour se qualifier au
second tour notamment terminé jean
garrigues
marine le pen dans sa prise de parole
elle eu beau jeu de rappeler qu'elle
serait candidate alors que jean luc
mélenchon s'étaient pas sûr et examens
non plus oui ça paraît quand même si en
sciences réfère à l'histoire des premier
ministre de cohabitation il veut devenir
ils ont tous été élus que ce soit
jacques chirac edouard balladur ou
lionel jospin ils se sont présentés aux
élections législatives pour devenir
ensuite ce qui est le rôle d'un premier
ministre le leader d'une majorité oui il
ya une logique institutionnelle à les
nommer le leader
j'ai été troisième c'est moi qui suis le
premier à gauche donc gg vocation à être
premier ministre et c'est vrai qu'a
priori ce que les projections nous
disent c'est qu'il a peu de chances de
le devenir mais c'est une sorte de saint
petit coup de prestidigitation parce que
c'est contraire je le répète à la
logique institutionnelle parlementaire
dos les jambes et donc il doit prendre
le risque de se présenter on est bien
d'accord moi je suis jeune j'ai
l'espérance que ce serait que ce serait
souhaitable qu'il se présenterait dans
l'esprit pourquoi parce qu'il ya quand
même un enjeu derrière tous enfin pau
pour l'historien que je suis passionné
par l'histoire parlementaire c'est
l'arrêt relégitimation la réhabilitation
du contre-pouvoir parlementaires de
notre législation et partir si vous
voulez de cette réhabilitation que comme
il le dit mais en partant d'une hyper
personnalisation et en partant de son
score à l'élection présidentielle ça
paraît un tout petit peu contradictoire
une micro nuance quand même en 90 sauf
erreur de ma part en 97 lionel jospin
est nommé premier ministre il n'est plus
député il a été battu aux législatives
de 93 et il n'a été relevée jti mais que
par la présidentielle de 95 il faut façe
qu'est gens parce qu'en fait quand on
écoute jean luc mélenchon il dit qui en
a eu six avant lui alors apparemment il
y en aurait 7 premier ministre qui ne
sont pas privés
sa tion
évidemment
sauf erreur de ma part n'était pas
immense et au moment il me semble qu'il
a des qualités lanka vérifier trop
peut-être
merci à tous en tout cas et on va
essayer de vérifier ça traîne
merci encore une paire et à boire ça
tous réglés comme ça la tentation du
sauveur c'est le titre de votre livre
jean garrigues aux éditions il sort chez
payot et puis 2022 la flambée populiste
mathieu soupière aux éditions plon merci
encore merci à tous d'avoir participé à
ce débat